a veces solo quiero ser un adolescente
pero no puedo hacerlo porque siempre
pienso que todo lo que haga ahora
afectará a mi vida en los próximos años
saben
[Música]
invitamos a 5 adolescentes para ver el
rango de sus valores y creencias
les pedimos que expresaran su acuerdo o
desacuerdo respecto a algunas de las
afirmaciones sobre ser adolescente
soy adicto a las redes sociales
utilizo las redes sociales pero no creo
ser adicto creo que no las necesito
puedo dejar de usar mi teléfono cuando
quiera eso es impresionante yo no puedo
hacerlo yo
siempre estoy usando mi teléfono todo el
tiempo como que deba para mí está grande
va a ver mis mensajes debo ver qué está
pasando es difícil no puedo concentrarme
en mis estudios bueno personalmente yo
use redes sociales porque creo que dos
semanas pero luego decepcionarme al ver
que las redes sociales pueden sacar lo
peor de las personas decidí que no
usaría redes sociales y si en verdad
necesito hablar con alguien puedo enviar
un mensaje o llamar o hablar en persona
si a mí me dejaron tener bueno hace tres
meses al cumplir 18 porque antes no lo
tenía permitido y debo compensar por el
tiempo que perdí y todo lo que pasó y
todas las fiestas a las que no fui
porque no podía ver instagram no creo
usarlo todo el tiempo pero siento que lo
uso demasiado algo así como seis horas
sí lo sé es lo que no sé es mucho
me gusta mi apariencia
creo que siempre van a haber cosas que
no me van a gustar pero en general estoy
feliz de cómo me veo y sé que las cosas
que puedo cambiar las cambiaré pero si
no puedo no valdría la pena pasar mi
vida
sin disfrutar mi apariencia física
yo me respeto a mí misma por supuesto
pero siento que nunca seré suficiente no
sé si tiene que ver con mis problemas de
salud mental pero no estoy feliz con mi
apariencia pero si de quién soy
siento demasiado estrés para mi edad
yo no debería tener que estar así de
estresada siento que hay demasiada
presión sobre nosotros respecto a
nuestro futuro
entonces termino reprimiendo me a mí
misma por las cosas que hice o
analizando en exceso lo que voy a hacer
en el futuro y no puedo literalmente no
sé cómo vivir el ahora a veces solo
quiero ser un adolescente pero no puedo
hacerlo porque siempre pienso en que
todo lo que haga de aquí en adelante
afectará mi vida en los próximos años
personalmente me gusta el estrés siempre
pienso en el futuro y lo que quiero
hacer y si quiero hacer todo eso en el
futuro debo empezar ahora aunque me
gustaría no hacerlo porque me gustaría
divertirme en lugar de trabajar en eso
en mi caso el estrés ha afectado mi
salud mental y física que a los 14 no
debería estar pasando digo debería
dormir tranquila y no beber café para
mantenerme despierta
los tiroteos escolares me hacen temer ir
a la escuela
debido a eventos recientes parece una
posibilidad es una realidad para los
estudiantes especialmente en escuelas
públicas pero no no voy a preocuparme
por eso todo el día porque no tiene
sentido a mí no me preocupa demasiado
porque mi escuela es muy pequeña y no sé
por qué motivo alguien haría algo como
eso pero si no eres feliz ahí podrías
cambiar de escuela o solo abandonar creo
que al menos en nuestro caso en nuestra
escuela ya estamos en confinamiento los
profesores están cubriendo las ventanas
con papel negro y eso me asusta más que
cualquier otra cosa solo hablar de eso
no me asusta pero es como si los
profesores están tomando medidas y si la
escuela no está esperando eso me asusta
me importan los eventos actuales
3 2 1
me importa porque creo que muchas de las
cosas que están pasando son
irreversibles pero es difícil sentir que
haces la diferencia ahora ya que somos
jóvenes incluso las cosas que creemos
que no nos afectan van a afectarnos en
algún momento si no hacemos nada muchos
vivimos en nuestras burbujas nos
encerramos en los celulares y es
importante saber lo que pasa en el mundo
mi familia es de nicaragua por eso sé
qué pasa ahí pero también me interesa lo
que pasa en otros lugares porque es
importante y me gustaría que todos
hiciéramos lo mismo puede que no sepamos
cómo o por qué pero sabemos que va a
afectarnos estoy un poco en desacuerdo
con lo de estar encerrados en nuestros
celulares porque creo que el internet y
los celulares en general pueden pueden
proveer información y fuentes que se
transmiten más rápido que antes estoy de
acuerdo en serio pero lo que quiero
decir con eso es cuántos de nosotros
leemos estos artículos porque la mayoría
solo vemos instagram pero qué está
pasando en nicaragua
dictador
limitó su acceso a la salud y a los
seguros sociales así que ellos se
alzaron contra él y a muchos los
encierran o te matan ha habido casi 400
muertos y miles de heridos
qué horror eso debería ser un titular si
yo suelo ver los titulares no tenía idea
yo yo en verdad no había escuchado nada
sobre eso si los adolescentes ahora
tienen más influencia que en
generaciones anteriores
hicimos una marcha hace poco cuando pasó
lo de los tiroteos y un chico de un
grado inferior lo organizó y lo hizo por
redes sociales y fue como hola a todos
iremos al ayuntamiento y esto es lo que
haremos pero creo que no habría sido
posible hablando cara a cara pienso que
tenemos más influencia de la que creemos
porque se trata de lo que pensábamos y
nuestros principios
el poder que con nuestros teléfonos
podemos transmitirles a millones de
personas un mensaje y con toda la
tecnología tenemos más influencia que en
generaciones anteriores
y muchas gracias a todos por participar
mente
[Música]